as
[Silence]
muham We are
continuing our
reading of some of the chapters
of authored
by may Allah subhana wa tala
be have mercy upon Him forgive him
enter in into
Paradise we
discussed Prophet sallallah alam's
character we discussed his physical
characteristics and then we began to
discuss his
Miracles that he was given throughout
his lifetime as a prophet
we took many of them and there are
many many more which the no we mentions
he mentions them rather quickly but in
order for us to understand them we have
to give them a little bit of context we
have to little mention a little bit of
the
backstory and some of these we've
heard of many of them perhaps we have
not unless we have pursued this topic
and this subject more extensively
than than
[Silence]
usual
can
[Silence]
another miracle that AI mentions is the
Mir CC that happened on his way from
Mecca to Medina when he stopped off at
a woman's residence her and her
husband and they were very
poor but more importantly it was during
a time of drought so there was nothing
really for the animals to graze on and
they were basically Skin and
Bones no milk could be taken
extracted from these animals and so the
prophet sallallah wasam asked permission
to milk
her sheep she allowed it and Allah
subhanahu waala provided an abundance of
milk for he those with him and the
people of the
residence
[Silence]
can
another miracle was the incident
which
occurred and this is known in the books
of s it's recorded by
and and others in
which his eye actually came out was
during
battle and his eye was actually in his
hand and the prophet sallallah alai
wasallam took it and returned
it in a way and kind of wiped over it
and his eye was just as good as the
healthy one for the rest of his life in
some narrations he mentioned that it was
the better of my two eyes after this
happened he
[Silence]
says
for
[Silence]
another
instance another incident which
occurred was
when who had an infection in his
eyes and his infection was so intense
that his eyes had swollen shut couldn't
see it all and this was during the
Battle of or The Siege Siege
of is is was a land of farming and it
was a hen it was a city that was
about
you know a few
dozen perhaps
50 or
more kilometers away from Medina towards
the Northwest Northwest of Medina it was
a was known as well known and during the
seventh year after Hijra the prophet
sallai
was went to lay Siege on
this
foress and they were there for many
days and there are a number of of Rooks
and towers and so forth that fell it
wasn't just one battle it was a very
long extensive exhausting
Siege but the prophet sallallah alai
wasam had a they had a particular
difficulty with one of the last Towers
to fall and he sent Abu Bakr and in
charge of an army he sent Omar in charge
of an army or should we say a battalion
or band of troops and they were unable
to
successfully penetrate The
Fortress so the prophet sallallah Ali
wasallam then said that
evening tomorrow I will give the
banner and make a
general a man who loves Allah and his
messenger and Allah and his messenger
love him Allah
will Mark the fall
of at his hands or the conquest of at
his hands this is not something that
could just be guessed it's not something
that could just be
assumed was not a little tiny
Fortress that you know no it was it
was a very fierce battle it took many
many weeks and as a matter of fact it
could could have potentially gone on for
years and the reason for
that is
that was a farming
Community they would be able to sustain
themselves for years without having to
leave their Fortress if if if need be as
well they had access to water they
had access to
you know resources and they had many
strong troops they had an army to
protect their
fortresses so the statement that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam made
that tomorrow I will give the banner to
a man and he will this will Mark the
fall in the conquest of this is an
incredible prophecy in
itself so the next day
the prophet sallallah alai wasallam
revealed who this man was to be and that
is and he was not present meaning he was
back at Camp he wasn't present at
the place where this conversation
took
transpired because he had an infection
in his eyes he was very sick he was
unable to see his eyes had swollen
shut Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
sent the companions to go get him they
brought him leading him he was a
practically blind at that point and the
prophet sallallah alai
wasam blew or spit into his eyes and
he was immediately cured from this
infection he then gave him the banner
and the fall of was that same after
[Silence]
afternoon and there are other instances
of
healing one instance
the the prophet Sall wasam was able to
place his hand over the leg
ofd and he was and he was cured
immediately his leg was
now as we've mentioned before the
prophet Sall alai wasam
his
miracles they are
all derivatives meaning they are they
are either equals or superior to the
Miracles that Allah spoke of in the
Quran so the prophet sallallah alai
wasallam brought the Quran with him that
was his Revelation and in the Quran
Allah subhanahu waala speaks
about who was able to cure the ill
and who was able to speak to the dead
Etc and and the Prophet Muhammad
sallam was given of
similar of
similar Miracles likewise Miracles
similar to those of Yousef Miracles
similar to those
of etc
etc
[Silence]
s
was
another of his miracles was informing of
the developments and the
particulars with regards to the Battle
of B on the day before or just prior to
the Battle of bad the prophet sallallah
alai wasallam
went around the area where the battle
was to take place the Battle of Bud and
his companions were with him and he
would gesture to seemingly random spots
in this open arena where the battle
would take place and he would explain so
and so of the mushin or so and so of his
companions will die here so and so will
die here so and so will die here and
things unfolded precisely as he
[Silence]
informed
what
[Silence]
another of his
miracles was the incident in which he
was forced to
kill was a very arrogant man he was a
very wealthy Merchant in Mecca and he
was somebody who spent a lot of time and
effort and money in harming the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam any way that
he could and he would see him often in
Mecca and one time he saw him by himself
and was feeling
particularly froggy that day and he said
I'm going to kill you you know that
right he said that to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam I'm going to
eventually kill you and the prophet
sallallah Al wasallam said actually it
will be I who kill you this was years
before Hijra years before any kind of
jihad before any kind of you know the
Muslims were in any shape to defend
themselves against their aggressors
and so the days
transpired one thing led to another the
prophet Sall made hij the Battle of B
occurred the Battle of
occurred happened to be there at the
Battle of we know some of the
generalities of what happened on the day
of but after it's very it's almost
bizarre
because this incident happened with OB
after the battle was over this wasn't
during the Skirmish it wasn't during the
battle battle was over it had fizzled
out everybody had kind of retreated to
their to their
you know to their to their camp
and each was kind of assessing the
damage and so forth and
and calculating their losses and
seemingly out of nowhere
comes riding on a horse charging at the
prophet s.
wasam he didn't have to be there he
shouldn't have been there but he was and
the prophet sallallah wasam took a spear
and he was skewered off of his horse
and perished in the way that the prophet
s. wasam had foretold him many years
[Silence]
prior and
s
[Silence]
was
another
example is a dream that the prophet
sallallah Ali wasallam
had and
was around and he had fallen asleep a
light sleep he woke up smiling she asked
him he said I saw in a vision that a
group from amongst my nation my
companions are going to actually go in
to battle and they will also spread this
religion even Beyond the Sea it's going
to be to the point
where the religion now is expanding
to the point that we have to take it
over water go to new
continents and he informed her that she
would be one of them and that she would
be
martyred in the on this occasion and
as he informed her many years later she
did she actually was the first to be
martyred in that
particular Conquest as soon as she
took her or rode her animal off of
the boat the boat docked and they were
you know riding their animals off and
her animal either tripped or bucked and
she got bucked off and she was
martyred in that
way
[Silence]
and
another instance of
Prophecy is that and no we mentions here
is a narration in sah Muslim on the
authority
ofan this narration is a a well-known
narration in which the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam LED his
companions in prayer and he continued in
for a very very long time
before right and this is a time of Dua
time most encouraged to make Dua in
Salah is in and after
before in the sitting position and so
the prophet sallallahu alaih wasallam
spent an excessive amount of time in
that position before he exited his
prayer and ended it he then informed his
companions that were present that Allah
subhah had promised him the riches and
Treasures
of the east and west of the of the
world of all of the Earth for his umah
that they would reach as far as the West
takes them as far as the East takes them
that this religion would reach these
distances and that wherever this went
it will conquer and it will
be supported and bolstered by Allah
subhah this is a very well-known time
that he's referring to in the history of
this
and things unfolded as he said and
person might say well you know maybe
this
was these these are things that are
mentioned by the scholars of Islam as
prophecies Miracles
because there's no possible way a person
could guess something this it's
just even if things look they will
end up a certain way
War Conquest things could turn on a dime
you
know I mean I mean people people came to
the
West they believe that they reached the
Spanish came to the Central America and
these places and you know it was all
these riches all of this gold and so
forth what they didn't expect malaria
malaria wiped them out a plague
bugs they didn't expect that right these
are things that cannot be predicted not
in this way especially in 20
years these nations these Empires
that
grow over hundreds of years to be able
to Venture into other territory and
Conquer other lands this takes hundreds
of years of refining Warfare and
strategy and and resources and so forth
this is not something that
happens in 10 or 20 or 30 years the
prophet sallallah Alam informs us that
the
riches of
Persia will be
to his companions
Persia was considered to
be un defeatable how do you how do you
defeat Persia they're so big it's it's
hard to imagine the world at that time
without the Persian
Empire it's just it's hard to imagine
something like
that yet the prophet Sall
wasam
informed his companions that this would
happen and it happened within 20 years
in the time
[Silence]
ofis
Al
[Silence]
for
Z
[Silence]
for
another thing that he informed his
companions of in more than one narration
uml informs us that the prophet
sallam said to the I do not fear
poverty over you I'm not I'm not worried
that you guys are not going to
find sustenance I'm worried about the
opposite I'm
worried that when Allah subhanahu waala
gives total Victory and authority to the
Muslims this that it will make us it
will make you weak and soft and it will
make you love the dun because of the
riches that you experience and the
luxuries and the illusory luxuries of
this
world and as he informed so it
occurred
[Silence]
am
Malik
[Silence]
l
Paris
[Silence]
Mal
another example of a very precise
prophecy
right
prophecies you know
alhamdulillah Allah subhanahu wa taala
always gives
us
contrast right so for
instance we
had in during the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam lifetime we
had a number of people who claimed to be
prophets at the same time we even had
women that claimed to be Prophet
prophetesses at that time
and each of them was claiming to be
sent along with
muhammad. the reason that these things
occur is so that people can see the
contrast between a real prophet
and a false
prophet
but we have the prophet Muhammad s.
wasam and then we have false prophets
people who claim the same thing he was
saying however we see their
behavior so for
instance we most of us know him he heard
of the
propheus from another area and so of
course the logical thing for him to do
is what to go try to marry her right and
so they got married she got married to
him without a without Witnesses she got
married to him without without M the
dowy was
actually I
hereby relieve and this is show you how
false prophets this this is the thought
process I relieve your people from
don't have to
pray this is a relief right this
shows
you the psychology of these
people and they made many of these
claims heard that the prophet s.
wasam a little boy was brought to him
and the boy was obviously not growing
any hair on his
head this is
troubling and so the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam wiped over the boy's
head and he had one of the fullest head
of hairs after that sayma heard about
this he wanted to try it too right so he
wiped over his head and whatever little
hair this kid had fell out
and that kid was known as the bald kid
who was touched by
m and many other instances this
whenever he would hear of something that
happened with the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he'd try to
he would try to emulate it and he would
fail exactly miserably
immediately and even his followers
knew that he was a liar they we F they
followed him mostly out of tribalism
it's not they believed he was a
prophet or messenger they say you know
we know you're a liar but you're one of
us and this is what led to the Battle of
yam
so these different prophets that would
these different false prophets that were
around in the time of the Prophet
Muhammad Sall Al wasallam was these were
important parts of
History why
because if the claim is is that the
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam this is of course just an
argument the argument is is that he was
not a prophet
right then these people were not
prophets
either but why is it that
he was succeeded made to succeed and
they all failed
terribly why is that even though they
had more resources than he did much more
resources even
though these other false prophets gave
the people what they wanted I mean
that's one of the hard things about the
prophet Muhammad's da is that he
couldn't give people what they
wanted I can't I can't allow you to
worship idols I I can't they came they
came to barter they said Hey listen you
worship our Idol a little bit we're
worship your God a little bit everybody
does a little bit of everything you know
love we love each other we we all get
together and we work together he said
absolutely not that's not even something
that can be
suggested these other guys they didn't
have that problem because they're Liars
anyways they're just trying to appease
people and so they did everything they
could to Garner as much attention and
support as they could but but they
failed within five years all of them and
this is an important part of history for
us to see during the time of the Prophet
sallallah alai wasam so that we have
that contrast if there was a false
prophet what would it look this is
what it would look this is what it
would look if it was a woman this
is what it would look if it was a
man an Arab a non-arab
etc we will
stop there for this evening inshallah
continue next
[Silence]
week